- [Narrator] An American
hero is on that train.
Her name?
Kate Warne.
She was the first woman
detective in the U.S.,
and on that very train she
saved Abraham Lincoln's life.
(train whistle blows)
When Kate Warne applied for a position in
the Pinkerton Detective Agency,
the detectives tried to turn her away.
They didn't think a
woman could do the job.
Kate argued the women can be
very good at uncovering secrets.
She won the men over and became
America's first female detective.
She proved to be a gifted investigator,
working many cases and going undercover
in the years leading up to the Civil War.
In disguise as a rich southern socialite,
Kate uncovered a plot to assassinate
newly-elected Abraham Lincoln.
The killers planned to intercept him along
the train route on his way to take office.
Kate and her agency worked
with the president-elect
to carry out a daring plan.
After a dinner in Philadelphia,
Lincoln threw on a disguise and
snuck to the train depot in secret.
He met up with Kate,
who posed as his sister.
She had bribed the conductor to reserve
the back of the train car to hide
her and the undercover president-elect.
The plan was a success.
Kate stood guard over
Lincoln while he slept.
Neither his assassins
or the other passengers
knew he was on the train.
Legend has it her watchful eye during
that sleepless night is the inspiration
for the term private eye.
American history could
have forever been changed,
if not for the first female
detective, Kate Warne.